[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today so I'm
holding an article here from cnn.com
written by Nicole Goodkind
the headline is U.S debt Rises to 33
trillion as Government shutdown Looms
article begins as the U.S debt passes 33
trillion in a government shutdown looms
Wall Street feels defensive
the shutdown could sour sentiment and
deal a blow to an economy already
dealing with high gas prices Auto worker
strikes and elevated inflation with some
saying it could even increase the
possibility of a recession let me be
real clear if the government shuts down
you're going to see catastrophic losses
across the board because the world
depends on one thing the United States
to pay their bills
and we have a group of
grown-ups sitting in a sandbox throwing
sand at each other and they're going to
set off a bomb
in the name of or a Instagram post or in
the name of a sound bite for their next
campaign and they're gonna
what a catastrophic mess so Jade when I
see U.S debt rise to 33 trillion
um this is me just being honest and
vulnerable with my friend here in front
of I don't know a couple of dozen
million people come on
it sets off an anxiety in me does it
like it it it it it will if I if I if I
dwell on it it will make it hard to
breathe because
I'm doing what I can in my home and I'm
looking at the world I got a
seven-year-old little girl and a 13 year
old boy I'm looking at the world they're
inheriting inheriting
and it makes it hard for me to wrap my
head around the world they're going to
be living in because a bunch of adults
act like such immature bratty children
and have created such a quagmire
and I see this number going up and up
and no matter who you vote for whatever
side you vote for
everybody's lying to you so get in and
do what they want to do
help me help me 33 trillion dollars is a
lot of money I mean and here's the thing
I can't do anything about it I mean when
I see things like this I I'll be honest
I'm almost on that exact opposite
spectrum of you I don't bat much of but
that much attention to it I mean I see
it and I go that sucks that's bad
um but you can only control the
controllables and for most of us that's
looking at our own house like these are
the times a lot of times we're like zoom
out zoom out this is the time where I'm
like zoom in like zoom in and don't look
at the giant statistic don't look at the
big scary monster zoom in and go okay
what's my part in this am I
participating in this do I have a say in
this can I control this and what can I
control do you know what I'm saying
absolutely and I think I get a lot of
peace out of that of going okay I I know
where my power lies and I know what
control I have and that over there has
zero to do with it yeah because I can't
do anything about it right I can't do
anything about that all I can do is make
sure I'm not contributing to to the
problem make sure you know because all
of this is connected it's all connected
and as American people we what we do
affects the economy that affects
National economies that affects all of
this U.S debt Global economies and so
Play Your Part yeah like shoot your shot
and play your hand the right way and for
most of us that looks like handling your
financial household as well as you
possibly can being a good Steward of the
money that you have because here's the
thing no one can point the finger at the
government and no one can point the
finger at red or blue if in their own
house it's a hot mess right and we
already know that most Americans that's
that's what it is so instead of getting
so like and I'm not yelling at you but I
know you got your stuff together no but
but it's good because it's it's I'm
allowing myself to be distracted yeah
right I'm allowing myself to be
distracted and to be frustrated at
things that I really can't do I get a
vote every two years and I get a vote
every four years and that's that's the
game that I'm in and that's the game I
get to play and so I get to make my vote
um
so this reminds me of a call Dave and I
took right after covid um maybe it was
2021 early 2021
um and it was from a school teacher in
New York who I mean the lockdowns were
very severe and were teaching an
elementary school I don't remember
exactly what she was teaching but an
elementary school teacher on on zoom and
she just looked at her student loan debt
which I think was 100 000 bucks she
owned a bunch of money owed a bunch of
money
and she just said I'm done
and she worked like a maniac she got up
before the crack of dawn and drove and
delivered food she got she taught all
day she worked until late lately late
yeah and she just burned through and
paid it all off like she just said I'm I
cannot do this and so I want to
challenge people I love what you're
saying like control you can control we
say that all the time so here's me doing
this in real time I feel this
my body feels 33 trillion dollars and
the fear I have for my little girl and
my little boy
also
I also feel the fear of our elected
officials acting like freaking children
I'm gonna shut you down I'm gonna shut
I'm gonna take the my ball and go home
instead of getting in a room and saying
hey I don't care who wins because if you
win and I lose we all lose can we help
solve this problem for this country
please so instead of that
um I'm gonna feel those feelings they're
real sure and then I'm gonna go do the
next right thing which is make sure I
don't owe anybody any money make sure my
neighbors are know that I'm a resource
for them if they need some support and
vice versa and I'm gonna keep my eyes
open for other people I can serve and
love and I'm gonna turn the news off and
um
I mean it's that I'm gonna double down
on relationships because what else can
you do right it's that cliche that we
hear it's on t-shirts some mugs it's you
being the change that you want to see
that's it you cannot point fingers and
say oh look at them they're doing this
these are terrible people these are
horrible are you a good boss are you a
good you know are you a great person to
work with are you a great spouse are you
handling your money like that's what we
have to do is look back and go okay I
can't just keep throwing stones I've
gotta do the best that I can do for me
in my house and set an example the more
you put in the world light pushes out
dark that's all I'm saying yeah
and remember oh I don't get political
it's funny you're striving not to get
political I'm striving not to get
spiritual because I I go straight I go
straight to the top on stuff like this
I'm like oh what is your hope truly in